We have three ways to declare
variables in JavaScript. We've
got var, which we've always used.
Now we have two new ones, which
is let and const. These two
have some attributes about them
which are going to be helpful
for us  , but we
first need to do a quick, quick,
quick review of the var keyword
in order for us to understand
the benefits and just the
differences between let and
const. First thing that we need
to know about var variables is
that you can reassign them. You
can also update them. Let's
console log the width, and we'll
update the width to be 200, and
then we'll console log the width
again. When we refresh this,
you see we get 100, 200. Not a
big deal. We're able to update
them. What you can also do is
you can put a var in front of it.
Now, this is not something you
should ever do, but we've all
been there where we run out of
names for variables and we
accidentally use the same one
over again. What's going to
happen here is it doesn't do
anything. It works as you'd
expect, but it doesn't yell at
you for creating the same
variable name twice in the same
scope. That's one thing about
var variables is that they can
be updated or redefined.
Another thing we need to know
about var variables is how they
are scoped. Scoping essentially
means, "Where are these
variables available to me?" Var
variables are function scope,
which means that they are only
available inside the function
that they are created. If
they're not created inside of a
function at all, like the case
is right here, they are globally
scoped. They're available on the
window, which is why we can type
width into DevTools here. But
what if I created a function
here and put my var width inside
of it, and console logged the
width, and then I were to run it?
Is that going to work? Of course,
it's going to work because this
width is available inside of
this function. What if I also
tried to console log the width
after I've set the width? Is it
going to work? It doesn't work.
Why doesn't it work? Because
width is only scoped to that
function. It is a local variable
to this function. It is not
available outside the confines.
I like to think of these curly
brackets of your function as
gates, and they are not
available outside the gates.
They're in function jail,
as far as you can think
about it. That's important for
us to know. What you could do is
you could say "var width" above
here, and you could just update
it instead. Now, we've globally
scoped a variable and we're
updating it. That should work.
Generally, it's probably not
what you want to do. You want to
keep your variables inside of
your function. If you need
something outside of it, you
want to return it and store that
in a variable. That's something
that we need to know about
function scoping. I'm going to
show you a use case where
function scoping sort of comes
back and bites us. Let's say we
have an age variable and we have
an if statement. We want to
create a number of dog years. If
they are greater than 12, let's
calculate their ages in dog
years and console log, "You are
dog years old." If they are
greater than 12, we just want to
console log. I'm using
in this. We're going
to learn all about this in the "
Template Strings" video. We'll
give that a save, and it works.
The one thing that is a little
bit funky here is that this var
right here, dog years, this was
just a temporary variable. I
just needed this real quick in
order to calculate something and
then stick it into a console log
or stick it into a string
somehow. What if I go into my
console and I type dog years?
Look, you can now see
that dog years, it leaked
outside of this if statement and
it is now a global variable. It
has now leaked. Even though
this was a temporary variable
that I only needed inside of
this if statement, because var
variables are function scoped --
there's no function here -- so
it's not going to scope it to
that function. It only has
scoped it or it has scoped it to
the entire window, which is a
little bit of a pain here. That
is one of the benefits to using
let and const. Rather than being
scoped to the function, it is
scoped to the block. What is a
block? Here is a great example.
Any time that you see an open
and a closing curly bracket,
that is a block statement.
Functions are also blocks.
They're still going to be scoped
to a function. However, if
inside of that function or if
inside of some other element
that you have, it will then be
scoped to that set of curly
brackets. If I now take this
dog years here and change it to
let, and I refresh, everything
works as we would want. But now
if I type dog years into here,
it says, "Dog years is not
defined." Why? Because I
declared it as a let variable.
It is only declared inside of a
block scope, now, not a function
scope, a block scope, and that
temporary variable has not then
leaked out. Similarly, we can
also use a const variable here
and it will work just the same.
If I type dog years, we have, "
Dog years is not defined." Let
and const, one of the attributes
of both of them is that they are
block scoped rather than being
function scoped. In the next
video, we're going to take a
deeper look at some of the other
attributes of let and const
variables.